brasil superó las 250.000 muertes por
kobe 19 la nación enfrenta una segunda
ola de la pandemia más virulenta y
mortal que la primera enardecida por la
circulación de nuevas variantes que el
ministerio de salud del país identifica
hasta tres veces más contagiosas que la
original esta nueva variante llegó y es
muy fuerte y altamente transmisible si
no hubiéramos detenido el contacto de
las personas de una manera más drástica
no tendríamos otra forma de contener la
ola creciente y nuestro sistema de salud
no está preparado para la demanda con
casi 66 mil nuevos casos diarios y más
de 10 millones 300 mil casos acumulados
el país tiene el tercer peor brote del
mundo después de eeuu e india en cifras
absolutas en esa situación las
esperanzas se posan en el plan de
vacunación el gobierno apunta a haber
inmunizado a la mitad de la población
brasileña a mitad de año y está
negociando con múltiples farmacéuticas
para adquirir el máximo número de
vacunas posibles a la vez que busca
intensificar la fabricación nacional sin
embargo el presidente del país
jair bolsonaro ha puesto en duda los
efectos secundarios de los fármacos 5
hay cláusulas en los contratos de
vacunas respecto a las que el
laboratorio no es responsable de los
efectos secundarios es una cuestión de
extrema responsabilidad para los
brasileños tener la última palabra
tras haber minimizado el impacto de la
pandemia desde el inicio el mandatario
ya avisó que no se vacunará